I want to touch if I may just on your
comment a moment ago about the the
parting speech that you left with your
colleagues in Congress and you were
there for four terms and I think are
aware of the general level of awareness
of your colleagues in Congress at that
time do they really not know that that
all of this is going on that the power
structure is there unseen but really
manipulating the strings most of them
don't know
most of them are suspicious that there
are the problems are more serious than
they would never ever admit publicly but
they don't understand the policies I've
had a lot of members on the Banking
Committee come up and ask me questions
how does the Federal Reserve System work
what are Special Drawing rights now what
is the IMF and they'll do that quietly
because they haven't really studied it
so most of them are naive but very much
aware that there's some serious problem
but if you get somebody that's ahead of
a committee that's been around for
thirty years or so I think that they
know very much what's happening they're
very much attuned to what's happening
and I don't think they get that far I
don't think they get to a head of a
committee unless they've more or less
been accepted you know by the power
structure I did a study or just a quick
look a few years ago after reading the
Joint Economic report on Joint Economic
Committee in Congress and reading it it
looked like it came right out of the
Trilateral Commission you look all the
little buzz words that the trilateral
commission reports had all the things
that's trilateral commission wanted that
so I looked to see if in the memberships
of organizations of these the
congressmen and Senators and sure enough
almost every one of her remember
trilateral commission of bilderbergerer
I can remember having a conversation
with barber Conable
one day she's a biggie at the party and
he was he was complaining about you know
there's people always complaining about
me belonging to the Trilateral
Commission he was complaining to me and
lo and behold it was barber Conable but
as soon as he resigned from Congress
where he end up the head of the World
Bank you know I I left Congress I
studied the banking system I understand
something about the money they even
called me yet to litter there's a boy
now I've been waiting it the telephone
waiting for them to wait but John you've
studied a lot on this banking industry
structure and it's not only interlocked
here but there are international
interlocks right there yes there are and
they ties with the foreign banking
interest we that people that settled
this country and left of course Europe
came over here and settled down and
almost immediately the the powers that
be in the European continent and the
money circles were reaching out those
tentacles to gain control of the new
country here and that struggle has
continued we see it and who shall
control our currency they struggled back
between Jefferson as a matter of fact I
have a quote from Jefferson that I think
is very pertinent to our discussion here
if the American people ever allow the
banks to control the issuance of their
currency first by inflation and then by
deflation the banks and corporations
that will grow up around them would
deprive the people of all property until
their children will wake up homeless on
the continent their fathers occupied so
he warned us that far ago and here we
are and his what he said is coming true
yes and his side certainly won the fight
back then they got the right position in
the Constitution they had a debate over
the money issue the hard money people
won the Federalists lost the
Hamiltonians lost but then subsequently
it's been downhill and certainly in this
century it never happens at one time you
know it isn't all or nothing they keep
changing away
we've got our central bank in 1913 it
wasn't a total destruction of the system
it literally took from 1913 to 1971 to
open up the floodgates but it was in 71
that the last linkage to gold occurred
of course in the 60s there were still
some linkage to silver but since
everyone all you have to do is look at
the economic record of spending and
deficits and all the economic problems
and interest rates and all the price
increases I mean it's just been totally
out of control and then even in 1980
there was another law that increased
tremendously the power reserves in the
savings loan yeah the most significant
increase in power to the Federal Reserve
System occurred since 1913 was in 1980
further enhancing and getting more power
into the Federal Reserve this was a time
when they introduced this idea that we
could use anything or the Federal
Reserve could use anything as an asset
to collateralize our Federal Reserve now
see in the old days you'd have gold and
silver as collateral to issue a note
which isn't too bad you know it's
collateral it would restrict the
monetary authorities and it would be a
certificate you know would be a
guaranteed certificate but it was then
that they changed it to say that you
could use any asset even a foreign bond
so it's true now that you can use and
they have use foreign bonds they put it
in the Federal Reserve and that's the
backing that's the collateral our
Federal Reserve that's how strong our
currency is you wonder how the currency
works it doesn't deserve to work and
someday that people going to wake up and
realize that money's worthless and
that's when you're in have runaway
inflation today we just have gradual
steady inflation depreciation of the
money causing a lot of harm and in
suffering but one day where the
countries would wake up and there's
gonna be a catastrophe I don't have to
focus on me and the Federal Reserve
itself for a moment in that I wonder you
know what percentage of the people know
that the Federal Reserve is not really a
part of the government the privately
owned corporation and who owns that you
know the Federal Reserve well could you
have a comment on that well I think very
few people understand how it works
because the members are
worked really not very much aware of it
but I think it's a little bit worse than
just saying it's private you know if
we're just private
they'd have to live within the laws of
the land openness fraud and they would
have to be a public corporation and you
know an open there's a public
corporation you have a right to know
what your corporation is doing if you
unstuck and be honest it here it's
secret but where do they get their power
is it the power of the marketplace that
creates this corporation no they in
addition to being very secretive have
their authorization their creation from
government so the government creates
them and they create a specialty so it's
much worse than just being a private
corporation
it is a very secretive private
government ordained corporation that has
the power to counterfeit money so it's
very very unique and much worse than
just being private it's the secrecy of
it and the power that it gets through
government legislation that makes it so
evil now you were the ranking Republican
on the House Banking Committee for a
while one of the subcommittee not on the
entire committee and do I understand
correctly that members of Congress are
can't even go to the Fed meetings that's
right I was very interested in the issue
and I was on three subcommittees to
being on coinage and domestic monetary
policy subcommittee but I could not go
to a meeting I couldn't get an audit I
could even check the books and they're
the ones who create the money and yet I
was I felt like I was elected to be
responsible to the people when I would
be inquisitive and looking into these
things their attitude is when you need
to know or when the people need to know
will tell you they're in charge and
we're just on the outside looking in
rather than the people being in charge
of the government sending me or somebody
else as their congressman to control the
bureaucrats but turn it upside down they
have control and they allow us to know
what we want and what they think we
should know